We searched the world for different brands, different companies...
...that make the highest quality of this type of furniture.
In addition to beds, we have many different product lines and types of furniture.
We have a new product which is the transformable ottoman,...
It's your essential ottoman and it's on small wheels so it's easy to move around.
And the entire ottoman deconstructs itself and turns into five different stools.
The next new item we have is the Goliath's table.
It's like an aluminum bridge and the table extends from 17 inches deep to 10 feet deep...
...and seats 12 to 14 people.
Now, this space that can be dedicated to something...
...it is actually functional day in and day out.
We have a new system, it's called the Poppi board.
It's unique because, first you have in a one single seven foot space,...
...you have hanging closet or shelf closet whichever you prefer.
It's two feet deep so you can hang seven feet of clothing in it...
...and the same space that you would put this closet you also have a bed.
Aside from the bed, you have a seven foot desk and then...
...behind the bed, when you open the bed, you have 14 feet of shelving.
In seven feet by three feet deep, you've got an entire room.